got this from the post millennial
faculty students and Alum at University
of Washington rally in support of Hamas
terror group yo check this video out
Greg price has it I'm GNA play this for
you ready here we
[Applause]
go peace unen land peace stolen land
there is only one Sol there is only one
Sol
re re so let me just break it down for
you they're saying there is no peace on
Stolen land and there is only one
solution Into Revolution so I want to
make sure the full context is there but
you know everybody understands the
reference to there is only one solution
right they're chanting that on purpose
that was yeah they don't need to say
that to you know so when these leftists
come out and they're saying things like
they go it's an it's an open air prison
and these people just want to peacefully
return to their homes I'm like no they
don't they're screaming from The River
To The Sea yeah they want to destroy
Israel Define peace CU I don't think
that word really means what you think it
means when you say that yeah if you
obliterate the surface of Earth it will
be peaceful after that but that's not
the kind of peace I'm looking for
interesting idea is there is it you know
that's how we bring about world peace
through a great reset Through Fire and
and Brandon cataclysm where was where
was that that was I think University of
Washington there's just something so
interesting about it happening to
sheltered
Americans protesting something
protesting something that's happening a
as far as they're concerned a world away
and I really do think that the internet
uh I don't think human beings were
really ever designed or created to to
Really handle what the internet can
provide for them in this respect meaning
that you lose an insane amount of
perspective to what's going on when you
take that vifer to something that you
can't even experience firsthand or even
would ever want to experience firsthand
that's as as it was the video was
playing surge I saw you shaking your
head you look pissed was it like were
you just picturing what these people
would be experiencing if if Hamas was to
take over as their government like what
was going through your head when you
when you heard them screaming that it's
just sickening to see people that are
living this first world lifestyle going
to University getting everything paid
for in a lot of cases and chanting for
the death of the people across an ocean
when they have nothing to do with this
the conflict they don't the roots of the
conflict I don't understand anything
else just know this current thing and
the current thing I have to spend on
this side and you know what I'm free
today I'm going to go rally for whatever
because I want to make sure that I get
cool social points it's sickening to me
you have this other video let me play
this one for you H they want our people
dead they
want how is itow how is it allowed she
asks the Tweet says Jewish students at w
campus witnessing the pro Palestinian
and rally break down they want us dead
how are you allowing this I will only
say young women wipe your tears they're
allowed to speak and I'm glad they're
speaking and you should be happy they're
saying these things because now you know
who the who they are and who to avoid
yeah imagine if there were people who
were trying to kill you in secret I'll
put it this way if like there's
someone's gunning for you they want to
take your life and they're lurking in
the shadows and you never even knew it
was coming yeah I that's that's horrible
but what if you got advanced warning you
go to the cops right you can say like we
like you know hey like someone's coming
after me that's the point of free speech
so we get to watch a video where they
chant that I think it's fair to say I'm
not taking their word for it when
they're saying things like no peace on
Stolen Land There was a Yale Professor
who said settlers are not civilians and
they're chanting there is only one
solution like bro the left lies it's
what they do they say we're just
defending ourselves as they throw bricks
and firebombs at people mhm and how many
times can you fall for it first of all
but but also kind of what you were
saying about the whole idea of
protesting even if it's peacefully about
something a see away is particularly I
think it's harmful on a level that they
don't understand obviously because
they're removed from it but also you're
influencing what that country kind of
does in a way the same way we were
talking about Co with all the and in the
middle of that all the George Floyd
stuff it's like why is London protesting
someone that was killed on our why why
is the UK and Paris like why and it's
it's you don't understand what's going
on and that's one of the things that's
uncomfortable on days like this where
obviously you know our job to talk about
politics but it's hard to really say
what we want to happen or what should
happen and then it's also even harder
because they're so comfortable saying
what they want to happen you kind of
feel like you have to but we don't
understand it here fully like that well
the funny thing is when George Floyd
happens you get all the conservatives
being like okay like this was bad we
agree and the left being like see we
told you black lives man then the video
comes out where it shows you a bit more
nuanced take on what what happened with
the George Floyd incident and you still
have conservatives being like we've had
conservatives come on the show and be
like yeah okay we saw the footage but we
still think it was bad what happened and
and and now you look at this now you
look at what happened in Israel and you
have the reasonable approach of we don't
like it when civilians are killed yes
Gaza is a hor it's a horrible situation
we're trying to resolve this what can we
do and then you have the left cheering
for the violence cheering for the
killing of civilians calling for more
chanting in the streets there's only one
solution like dude just stop believing
them they're lying to you they go
straight to it oh my God and they're
going to come out now and be like no
that's not what we mean I like I don't
even I don't want to hear it dude like
there was there's a really funny video
Indo tweeted where a guy claims that
when you go to a pro when what do he say
when you go to a leftist rally or
whatever there's Palestinian Flags when
you go to a white supremacist rally it's
Israeli flags and then he claims that
they they only chant free free Palestine
meanwhile people on the right chant
death to Arabs which literally is not a
chant and does not occur or appear in
any of the rallies held by people on the
right I'm rcking my brain I'm like when
was that oh yeah I saw that video right
yeah they they just lie they're making
things up and they want to kill people
and one of the Twisted things about
leftist rallies and protests and all the
things that are actually not protest
because they're violent having lived in
La during all of Co is that you realize
they're actually kind of parties like
they'll be doing this crazy rhetoric and
this group think but the 90% of people
who show up are because their friends
are there and they're showing up whereas
even the most intense right-wing rallies
which again I'm rocking my brain to
think of really like the worst ones
people are there at least intentionally
and at least they've had like a minute
of thought about what they're saying and
how the impact it may have whereas these
people show up and they're like oh
Rebecca's over here and she's talking
about no peace until what it's like that
doesn't mean you have to look at this
look at this story this is uh from the
post-millennial they go on when reached
for comment about the rally for
terrorists W spokesperson Victor Balta
told the post millennial on behalf of u
w president Anna cost as a public
institution that abides by the First
Amendment the UW neither monitors nor
takes any action against individuals or
student organizations for engaging in
protected speech however cost has a
track record of attempting to prevent
speech in 2019 the W College Republicans
held a bake sale to demonstrate racism
from affirmative action by charging
different prices based on ethnicity and
gender in response cost released a
statement condemning the event and
despite claiming University needed
reason to debate on affirmative action
added the so-called affirmative action
bake sale uh that the W College
Republicans are hosting today has no
place in such a debate she also said the
event humiliates and dehumanizes others
it's really interesting these PE look
the C professor said settlers are not
civilians basically saying that the
killing of civilians in Israel was
justified and has now like walked them
she's like walked the statements back a
little bit but she doesn't mean it yeah
I'm glad these people were able to speak
up and now we can say you know maybe you
shouldn't work here you're evil and they
would say the same thing about being an
American here in in many cases they
would have no problem making that
connection and they would have no
problem with the students taking those
viewpoints even if it's to their own
detriment living here that's one of the
benefits I mean that word is crazy to
use in this context but I'm sure people
know what I mean one of the only
positive things is sort of seeing who's
who and getting a lot of clarity about
your own positions we were talking about
that earlier like
my anti-war position has never felt I've
never felt more confident with it um but
I also am more confident in who's who
and who you know it's beaten those War
drums it has been absolutely like insane
to me to watch what's been happening and
realize that my positions have not
changed through Ukraine through
everything in 2020 that my beliefs you
know especially anti-war beliefs do not
need to be swayed by either side that
it's a bad idea no matter where it's
coming from you saw l grah right yeah
his his latest thing was where he said
that he wants to bomb Iran with even
with no evidence yep that was crazy
insane that guy should resign that dude
is evil and there's and you look at the
responses of the people talking about
this and there are people justifying it
and it's like when I when we started
seeing all this stuff it really did
become clear to me how the Patriot Act
got passed so quickly with so much
little push back and that's before the
internet age that's before the free
exchange of information that we have now
where there at least is now
uh reasonable push back from all parties
where the ones who are not seeing red
right now can have a reasonable
discussion back then that wasn't really
an option you had you had a couple of
mainstream networks pushing the war you
know the war machine on you and it
worked it worked it lasted for like a
year and a half too everyone sorry I
didn't know anybody that wasn't blood
lust from 2001 2002 well that what but
there's a weird sometimes I catch myself
almost like longing for sort of that era
in the sense of not the war part but the
unification we all felt but then you
remember it was unification under so
many false pretenses based on a lie
right and I don't even know how much of
that is safe to even talk about here how
many false pretenses so we won't go into
it but you know it is what it is and
every war really starts with
manipulation to some extent which is why
also free exchange information era but
also manipulation era because we have ai
which we're still in the infancy stages
up and we're still having people like
not able to diser what's fing what and
just too much information like like you
were saying earlier they say what they
say they lie you don't like most people
you do this for work every day we do
this for work every day you have the
time to look into all of these cases
fact check double check everything
you're seeing the average person who's
just going to the internet to get
information on what's going on isn't
doing that the the the the worst is that
they're taking advantage of the people
who are operating good faith who are
just looking to get information on what
they're supposed to understand people
don't understand what the world really
is without our system of laws and rules
and order it's uh you're in the middle
of the woods and you've You' got your
family and you built a house and you're
like man i' I've I've built up this nice
little place to live and grow food and
then three guys who don't feel like
doing any of that show up mercilessly
beat you and your family and take all
your stuff and leave you for dead and
it's funny because this is my argument
against vegans vegans listen up you see
here's here's my issue the the the the
little uh uh spin plant hurs nobody
grows its own food sources everything
from the environment around it
peacefully mining its own business and
then Along Comes This groundhog
groundhog comes over and just
mercilessly destroys that plant
consuming everything about it and I'm
supposed to sympathize with the animal
the animal is the Barbarian who came in
and killed the peaceful farmer so so
it's like if there was a guy farming
mining his own business and then a
bandit came and killed the farmer and
took all his stuff who would you side
with depends if the if the farmer's
father had stolen the land from the
Bandit's father now we're talking now we
have a great debate but this is actually
an interesting uh uh point if you have
an innocent farmer who grew his own he
has he has land there's nobody there it
was just wild and it's like let's say
it's 3,000 years ago and he's mining his
own business then Marauders come kill
him take all the stuff and leave we
obviously s with the farmer and say it's
awful they did this but you take a look
at how the left operates and it really
does follow this this line so it's like
it's interesting that they're like an
overlap between leftists and vegan
I'm not really wagging on vegans I know
a lot of conservative vegans I know
you're saying though but like my point
is the left tends to side with the with
the thieves with the people who who lie
cheat and steal and strip value they're
predators and and and also they're also
predators in the more literal sense of
what predators are like Joe Biden is a
predator but they also they a lot of it
is like in our media we' baked the idea
of the ends justifying the means for a
very long time and so for a lot of them
they feel as if their actions however
uphor are Justified because a lot of
times it really does come down to is it
class struggle is it race struggle uh in
this case they're saying that what's
going on they're attacking their
oppressors therefore it is okay and that
has permeated all levels of our culture
whether it's people pushing back on
police because they believe that they're
being held down by the police that
carries all the way all the way up
through to global conflict you know some
oppressors are better than other
oppressors and if you've got to pick
which one you want to be oppressed by
whether it's a banking system or a
militant system you got to pick like you
might maybe you'll end up on top of the
game at some point but I don't think so
I think there's probably about 10 10
humans that are doing that right now
that's that's the reality that's my
point if nobody nobody wants to live in
a true state of conflict or War right I
the people that that gloat about it and
laugh you put those people in the middle
of the woods for a couple weeks and
they'll be crying and begging and I I
know this because I remember during
Occupy Wall Street story often tell uh
they the land was gifted to the
occupiers and I ask I ask people how
long do you you think the occupiers
lasted on that Farmland how long do you
think I don't know bunch of leftists
protesting in New York farmland is
gifted saying you can use this Farmland
to live off the grid and be sustainable
I maybe 12 hours a it's a little you
know they did a little better than that
two weeks okay yeah two week couple
weeks and then they and then I remember
talking to a friend who said I was
working I would wake up and work and
then work till I went to sleep and I'm
like uh-huh you're surprised by this
yeah that's what life is like outside of
the luxury of the United St and the
Petro dollar and all this stuff you work
and they also don't really obviously
have a concept of so you can wrap your
head around maybe the more advanced
leftist brain can wrap his head around
the idea that you know bad things
happening into other places but the idea
that yeah that happens and there's no
justice for it in most scenarios too so
the idea that you can then seek Justice
for it is completely removed as well who
who are you going to complain to that's
why it's funny when they're like
universal healthcare and Healthcare is a
human right I'm like so who are you
going to force to give you the health
and then if that person is human and you
stripped them of their rights is it
really a human right right that's that's
like way more thinking into it than they
than most of them give to it anything
that involves the labor of another human
being is not a human right right yeah of
course and and what you said earlier
about how their idea of who the
oppressor is and who isn't is completely
warped you see it with their you know
landlord discourse oh that's it's like
so someone who worked their entire life
to maybe buy even a rinky dink house and
then manages to rent it out someone is
somehow like worthy of being bashed for
that or not in a position of being
harmed if that rer destroys the house or
doesn't pay rent it's like what people
these people don't understand like you
know I I I I I had a house we moved I
rented it out and then I sold it as soon
as I could because I'll tell you I'll
tell you what happens you're like the
the Assumption of the left because look
they're not bright people that's just
that's just the reality of it period
they don't understand what it means to
be a landlord because they assume all
landlords are slumlords okay be slum
Lord fine whatever but uh you you have
to maintain and work for the people who
live there they are paying you you are
providing a service that's it imagine
owning a restaurant and being like as
the owner of the restaurant I can sit
back and do nothing someone comes in and
says I'm giving you money for food and
you say get it yourself they're going to
be like okay I'm leaving give me my
money back you have a you have a house
and then AC stops working yeah you're
going a phone call you got to pay for it
and so basically all the money you're
making in rent off a single property or
a couple properties is is going to the
bank to pay to maintain the house now
that being said if you finance a house
and you have people renting it out you
are Building Wealth for yourself so
you're working right but people still
choose to rent or not and and one of the
biggest issues is i i i reject so much
of the millennial I can't afford to buy
a house and things like this because I
do know it is difficult it is difficult
but I've met way too many New York
hipsters who don't want to give up their
luxuries they refuse to have to save I'm
not kidding man like I 90% of the people
I worked with when I lived in Brooklyn
it's like well do you want to buy a
house I do well here's how much you're
going to need down you can buy you can
get a condo in New York you can get a
small a small house outside of New York
and then commute in well I don't want to
commute in well okay like property in
New York is ridiculous expensive that I
get but that's premium real estate so
how about instead of spending 300 bucks
every weekend you keep the 300 bucks and
then after a year you can have a down
payment now they don't want to do it and
you know what there's something so sad
about that because this is kind of
something I identified very early on cuz
I've kind of always even when I was a
teenager and you tend to be more
socially liberal and just liberal in
general when you're a teenager but the
time I was 18 or 19 was when I kind of
shifted that and I realized that's
because I'm not a pessimist there's
something very pessimistic about the
leftist mindset as well because it's not
just that they're demonizing the
landlord and see him as an oppressor
it's because inherently they believe
they could never achieve that and even
though granted it's
difficult to buy a house like you said
it's partly because they belied they
could never achieve that whereas I
always believed I could achieve anything
I wanted and so that's kind of how I
realized very early on that's not the
ideology for me social media has also
like really really ramped that up like
Doomer content that's designed to
destroy your morale and hope for any
type of brighter future like half the
memes you'll end up seeing they are it's
so funny that you mention that cuz the
do you remember maton Evan the guy who
mentioned um okay so he had a thing he
went to like protest and was like we
love landlords and it was like I think
that might have been the greatest thing
that happened in all of 2023 because the
landlord discussion is one of the most
ridiculous ones that's going on right
now and they've just been inundated with
all of these all of these things it's
it's people who are actually the funny
thing about it they're actually talented
they're just talented at creating
content that's destroying the morale of
other people there's this guy who does
these videos where he lists existential
crises and really really bad things but
he says it with a smile on his face with
really really positive words and that's
the type of stuff that seeps into their
brain it's like I'm never going to own a
home I'm going to work until I'm 80 like
in in all the while there's like cheery
music playing in the background and
that's in they're on social media all
day so they're being inundated with this
content endlessly who wouldn't be
demoralized and it becomes warped
because you see it spread out in so many
different ways like the fat positiv
movement which is inherently a leftist
movement it's like they really will
convince you that being fat sick and
dying literally is a virtue is positive
like living the opposite of a positive
life is positive modern society I think
has destroyed the human human psyche in
a lot of ways we should be working
non-stop like but the problem is for
whatever reason I never understood this
there are people who are like I don't
want to work I want to do nothing it's
like hold on if your argument is you
want to work on something specific and
not the thing you're working on that I
get yeah like hey I'm a restaurant
manager but I really want to be a
software engineer so I'm going taking
night classes to learn how to code and
then I'm going to go and work for a firm
that I get that's like I'm not working
where I want to be but a lot of these
people want to do nothing they they
they're just like I shouldn't have to
work I should be able to just lay there
and and and consume resources from other
people and a lot of those people who do
they actually like the like to what you
said your mindset you would see it as a
net positive to be able to have
something to work on after your day job
because you're passionate about it they
find it almost as an affront to them
that they would have to have a day job
to then work on the thing that they want
to advance in thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net